time for a game spot news update I'm
Sean McGinnis the latest free game and
EAS on the house program is dragon age
origins giving you just over a month to
play it before the release of dragon age
inquisition the EA on the house program
only requires you to open origin on PC
and claim your copy and the game will be
permanently added to your account dragon
age origins was very well received upon
release earning a 9.5 from GameSpot it's
normally priced at 20 bucks you only
have one week to claim your free copy
the offer expires on october fourteenth
dragon age inquisition the third title
in the Dragon Age series is launching
November eighteenth so this is a good
opportunity to get introduced to the
series if you've never tried it dragon
age inquisition will allow you to import
choices made from the first two games
without importing a save file so you
shouldn't have to worry about playing
the games on different platforms for
more dragon age coverage leading up to
the Inquisition review in November stay
tuned to gamespot com / news